what's going on there what did you learn
that you didn't expect going in
that there are pockets that are a lot
better than what we think they are that
certainly every soldier from the guy
that hung out of the helicopter that was
the specialist all the way up to the
three-star general said the same thing
that look we know bad things happen but
it's getting better i've been here once
i've been here twice things are better
than when i first got here and that
we're doing our jobs and we're
accomplishing things do you think the us
should keep troops in iraq for the
foreseeable future i think they need to
keep troops in iraq until the security
is there and i suspect that there will
be troops there over the long period
because if you think about the countries
where we've been successful in our
history we still have troops there
and the book indivisible is available in
stores now in stores now and on all the
regular internet places is there another
book
in the works actually
yes there is and just because you get
these great ideas about books so i'm
working on something else that i hope
will come up out in spring of 2007.
martha zoller thanks very much thank you
russian president vladimir putin will
host the g8 summit next weekend in saint
petersburg
andre poinkovski writes about the former
kgb agent's domestic and foreign policy
since 2001 in his new book another look
into putin's soul he spoke about it at
the hudson institute in washington d.c
where he is a visiting fellow this is an
hour and 40 minutes
okay let's begin please
uh one administrative note please
silence any communication devices that
you might have
i want to welcome
the panelists and the audience
thank you very much for taking time out
of your busy schedule to attend this
presentation i want to also especially
welcome the c-span audience and other
viewers on television
andrei poinkweski will speak first and i
will introduce the other panelists as
they make their presentations
andre is currently a senior visiting
fellow at hudson from 1994 to 2005 he
serves as director of the center for
strategic research a moscow-based think
tank he has written several books and
many articles for publication
andre has a new book
entitled on another look into putin's
soul and we have signed copies available
for sale outside and andre will also
stay afterwards to discuss his
presentation as well as meet with media
just as a reminder the g8 summit in
science petersburg will begin in less
than two weeks the perhaps the most
important relationship among the g8
leaders is that between president george
bush and vladimir putin
when they first met in slovenia in 2001
bush famously said i was able to get a
sense of his soul a man deeply committed
to his country and the best interests of
his country
since then russia has taken a number of
actions that have evoked criticism by
administration officials those include
curbing press freedom
changing the electoral procedures and
ways of harm the opposition parties and
a new law that appears to weaken the
role of ngos operating in russia
yet the two countries still cooperate
heavily on counterterrorism regional
security issues
and they just recently a few days ago
renewed the cost of threat reduction
program
certain quick questions naturally arise
for andre and the other panelists
did bush misread putin's soul at the
time
has putin's assault chains since their
first meeting andre putin's soul does he
have one
every human being have a soul
thank you richard and
you know that richard is a very tough
administrator and he warned all of us
that we have very limited uh
space
of time so i hope very much on active
questioning
uh to have additional time but
nevertheless first of all i i spent
at least 30 seconds second of my time
to express my
gratitude
to hudson institute colleague
administration first of all to ken
weinstein to our wonderful pr vice
president grace sterzian and to my old
friend and david setter for enormous
help
without which this event
would not happen
this book is a kind of
political diary
it contains
my text article says
from 1999
until the latest uh entry
is uh
uh dated uh this june
about political development uh uh in
russia
and you find that
i defined my let's put it madly as a
skeptical attitude uh
to
then candidate to the president and
acting president and president putin uh
from the very from the very beginning
and i think that events
validated is my assessment
uh i disagree with two
wide
spread perception uh about putin and
comparison with
his predecessor one apologetic
apologetic and one denouncing the
apologetic
um view uh widely presented now by
government official propaganda that
putin uh have been fighting with
oligarch system with anarchy of uh
yeltsin uh period he restore
the sovereignty of state restore order
um
in the country
uh well
it's very strange theory because uh
what's uh
may i remind you that putin was
appointed to be uh president of the
country by the same people uh
who he's supposed to fight the
one of the most repulsive uh figures of
this yeltsin oligarchy people boris uh
actually uh was the driving force of
all this
operation
success
yes in quran
was
threatened then by almost imminent
coming
to the power representative of azer
business political clan of russia
rushkoff and
which threatens them with a lot of
unpleasant thing
and
[Music]
they
the task before them was uh
formidable almost mission impossible uh
to
make an absolutely unknown figure uh not
only president of the country but as a
kind of uh national hero
and uh i
i
write about
this book detail the main instrument of
putin campaign in 1990 certainly was
checking
war
crimean collective karl rove invented
a slogan for him
to
wipe out
terrorists
in the sheet house and the swiss with
this slogan uh he uh waged his uh his
campaign
and became uh became a president and now
we see the consequences
of what happened it's not uh elimination
of system of uh
criminal capitalism
just uh elimination of some figures of
yeltsin uh period
and substituting them with new cronies
new oligarchs
of uh putin uh czechist
entourage
i it was
this uh direction of event uh was clear
to me enough when for example
uh
i wrote
an article
on january 20
2000 uh putinism uh during putin the
first election campaign putinism is the
highest and final stage of uh criminal
uh capitalism in russia no no liberal
paper by the way published
this
because i should add that
part of liberal intelligence in russia
this enormous
responsibility
for
the
putin coming to power and establishing
this regime they have been dreaming for
a long time about russian pinochet uh
who would
pay for
who would lead russia on the way of uh
economic reform by uh by by iron hench
well they go to president this uh um
natural for person of his background
disregard uh for democratic constitution
uh but no real liberal reform and uh
modernization if uh in first term of uh
of his prejudice some liberal minister
managed to introduce some reasonable uh
merits i think anders
will talk about it uh in more details
like
for attacks for example now it's uh he
it's uh uh absolutely that modernization
proved to be a banner straightforward
redistribution uh of uh valves uh
in the favor uh of new uh new persons uh
of power and this uh the essence of
oligarchic systems this incestuous
maj
union of money and uh and power of
business in power
well
states
and
this broke uh russian russian
russian breakthrough into into
post-industrial
society
[Music]
to our today meeting is uh um
on the eve of g8
summit and i would like to maybe
initiate our discussion making some
remark uh about uh russian foreign
police and putin
well my main my main
message is that putin is not uh
putting just logical continuation of
yeltsin regime both
in
in
you know its negative characteristic of
that regime
the people who uh
another another misconception the people
many people um denounce putin as a
person who uh will strangulate uh
flourishing democracy in russia it's not
the case uh the first
exercises of so-called managed democracy
where yes an election in
in 96 and as i already mentioned the
putin recession of power is also was
anything but triumph of democracy it's
the same
i think the same continuation in foreign
policy also not only
yields in period but well i would say
the weight is several hundredths of
russian history because
russian relationship with the west for
the latest 700 years is cyclic uh
period of uh
um
apparent and disengagement of uh
attraction and repulsion we saw uh two
such periods uh during the else and uh
yeltsin term uh
under foreign minister cody and foreign
minister primakov and under putin tom we
saw the same uh cyclic uh
cyclic um
change the putin uh we remember putin
who
uh on september 11th uh satan americans
we are we are with you
and this statement uh uh was supported
uh uh by
uh i think his very wise policy
in uh in afghan
conflict i have nothing personal about
uh
this guy in 2002
1 2003 i
actively supported
uh his uh foreign policy because his
foreign interest
of the russia
supporting americans
uh he led them uh to solve a very
serious uh security uh russian problem
like to liquidate the stronghold of
islamic
islamic
extremists radicals
on south border southern border of
russia maybe for the first time in
russian military history
somebody did
uh for us
dirty job it's american that is not of
charity for russia it was just clear
case of uh coincidence
of uh
of uh our security and strategic
interest i think
nothing has changed with this
fundamental fact
uh
i think that we face
basically the same challenge and we need
each other maybe more than
than
any time before
but today's putin's attitude is quite
different
he's
doing his best
to push out american
american bases from central asia for
what purpose well uh
what nato nato is trying
uh to hold
in afghanistan against uh resurgence of
taliban if the coalition uh in
afghanistan suffers uh defeat and the
situation is very shaky and fragile
we return to situation uh
on uh 2001. with the same threat of
taliban then by the way before september
11 we
our general staff planned
uh military operation in the central
asia bombardment of taliban
well fortunately this problem was sold
for us
by americans
uh well i have very few time but i just
several points why this change well
invite this chase general uh well
should we be just philosophical about
this shift in russian foreign policy and
in russian relationship with the west
before
because as i already mentioned well
historian counting 25 or 26 such cycle
of rashman and disengagement i think
it's dangerous because never before
uh west and russia
as a part of the west because
phrased such serious uh
civilizational challenges and uh
threats to its security in nineteenth
and twenty centuries uh west and russia
was a dominant sole dominant forces
on the water in now
they're more vulnerable
and more weak than ever before and they
need each other counterpart they split
up and another reason that unfortunately
the combination
of factors which provoke this
new
comment in russian
russian western relations have a
tendency uh have a tendency to continue
for a foreseeable future uh first of all
certainly it's a deep psychological
complex uh uh suffered
by russian political elite as a result
of defeating the cold war or also from
empire of status of superpower it
provokes a serious underlying animosity
to the west and by the way this decision
of putin in september 11 was taken
against
against
the
resistance
implicit or sometimes explicit of
majority of russian political class and
his
entourage the second reason is that as i
already mentioned
um
the
second term
putin's second term
make very clear
very clear the character
of internal economic and political
regime
and this regime needs
no
image of west as an enemy as maybe a
soul
justification
of authoritarian system because the
popular
justification of
some
level of authoritarianism in the russian
political system during first
term of putin was well it's necessary
for modernization of uh economy we
should uh well implement labor reform
and and so on now well nobody believes
this thing
and that's why propaganda
extremely actively intoxicates public
opinion this idea of
of america as an enemy and putin himself
contributed to this award
first of all but his
fantastic statement
after beswan that
islamic terrorists
they
just too in the
in the
hands of more dangerous more powerful
more uh traditional uh enemies of russia
the third region the reason is that
russian political leadership and
political class
generally is intoxicated now by us by
exorbitant oil prices but new sense of
assertiveness if you read russian uh
vote
media now on russia assertiveness is a
key
as a team uh as a q as a team vote but
unfortunately this new certainness
is understood and realized in moscow not
as a
certainness in
defending uh pursuing uh um
uh genuine russian security interest but
as in the case of uh uh
central asia just in
in uh in dark in the classical zero-sum
game uh
this uh
these united states
and the last uh
but maybe not the least uh reason for
stage development is this a set of
mistakes
blunders failures of the west uh
during uh where it is two or three years
created uh impression among parts even
jubilant impression uh among part of
russian political leads it's a west is a
sinking sheep and it's necessary uh
maybe to abandon this
ship as uh as soon as possible uh such
perception found
by the reflection in some concessional
statements
of russian foreign minister uh sergey
lavrov
if
putin said in september 11 americans uh
we are with you what lavrov is writing
his conceptual uh article i would
recommend uh many to read russian global
policy in moscow news americans we are
not with you whereas against with you
his famous formula is that
russia can take side
in the
unleashed
conflict
of
civilization it's a new definition uh of
uh what was perceived in both in russian
american official documents early as a
common struggle against international
terrorism at this uh raw formula
ironically
uh reminds uh it's classical remake on
of famous uh uh stalin foreign minister
motor formula in 1939 uh that soviet
union can take side in the world war
unleashed by uh angular french
imperialist
uh this and this reflected in practical
in many practical actions in blockading
said gentleman says
michelle in protecting them
in security
in security council
well
the problem the problem
is that
in spite of this attempt to dissect
itself from the west in the enemies
of the west in this enemies of islamic
fascists
russia is a part of this satanic
satanic
west and moreover it's
the most
vulnerable part
and
more attractive for
the
advance and the tragic
address of
russian diplomats
in several days after tragic deaths of
american soldiers in in the middle east
remind us about this
uh this truth reminds us again how for
both united states and uh
for both and and russia uh how important
for us is
to keep
together in this
very dangerous
20
21st
century and well i hope
very much that
on the coming g8
meeting uh
bushmake will make maybe another you can
put in so and they try
to talk frankly about about this problem
because what is going until now it's
pretending
until recently uh americanism pretends
about everything fine uh well a couple
of months ago state secretary madame
rice stated that
american russian relationship is as good
as they never been so for latest 40
years well let me say as an insider who
remembers soviet time
they
have never been so bad
because
because in the soviet time
well there were no
i think the last 20 years of
soviet uh american confrontation
was a kind of uh was perceived by
russian leadership and it's kind of
condominium uh of uh
managing the world and the perception
was that well we ussi and us were
playing in the super league and it was a
sense well confrontation but mutual
respect there were no
such
emotional
hostility generated
by these complexes
about
which
i mentioned
by this
but this strange mixture
of
inferiority complex and megalomania
complex
well i i
realized it was very very short uh
certainly and i certainly somebody asked
me and they're ready to uh to uh to tell
about american responsibility for this
was this uh splashing up as a as a
russian right and uh
russian
active politician
i am a member of uh
leadership of opposition yeah i more
concentrated certainly on their own
criticism of
of moscow and our president but my main
message that we just can't afford uh
with each other thank you very much
our next speaker will be carl gershman
who is president of the national
endowment for democracy
this is a private congressionally
supported grant-making institution its
mission is to strengthen democratic
institutions around the world
it also publishes the well-known
quarterly journal of democracy
carl also took the lead in launching in
new delhi in 1999 the world movement for
democracy which is a global network of
democracy practitioners and scholars
prior to assuming his position with the
endowment
he was senior counselor to the u.s
representatives united nations
like our other speakers carl has an
extensive list of publications thank you
thank you
and thank you especially to andre
i just got the book
over the weekend
but had a little time and was able to
read it and
i i think it's terrific but not so much
because he tells us a lot about putin
but because uh andre is is a russian
patriot
who is able to discuss the whole issue
of russia and its relationship with the
world in in a large way
and i think it returns us it takes us
away from the day-to-day issues although
they're there of course
that he's just been discussing
and and and brings us back uh to the
fundamentals uh the fundamentals of
russia's relationship with the west
the psychological issues that he was
just talking about at the end the
megalomania the inferiority
and and explains to us why this
relationship is so complex
the role of the political technologists
which appears in the book which are
playing such a insidious uh
insidious role uh
uh today
uh the whole question of russia's
relations with its neighbors its desire
to reestablish the empire it's hopeless
desire as he points out to reestablish
the empire in particular the book deals
extensively more extensively than
anything else i've read in some time
with the whole issue of chechnya
chechnya is an issue that is off the
table for pretty much everybody and i
think what andre makes clear in this
book is that chechnya is not an issue
that can be swept off the table it's not
an internal problem it's not a marginal
question it's a central question which
we have to deal with and should be
raised within the international arenas
not just with a resolution here and
there uh of the parliamentary assembly
of the council of europe or some other
place but at the g8 i mean these things
need to be talked about because they're
absolutely central and related to the
other very fundamental and large
question that andre raises in the book
which is the relationship of russia
and islam
um
just very briefly
that i think that what emerges from the
book is is a certain program of action
um i want to refer to
two items and then a third which is not
clear enough in the book and i want to
sort of challenge andre to speak a
little bit more about it the first i've
already said is is the whole question of
uh of chechnya uh at one point in the
book andre
andre writes that putin actually got it
right in something that he said about
chechnya
he said in 2000 he observed and the
final analysis the formal status of
chechnya is not all that important to us
what is important is that no threat
should ever arise to russia from this
territory and i think as he makes
perfectly clear the way russia has
dealt with this issue
uh it has dealt with it precisely uh so
that a threat will emerge from the
jihadists to russia from russian soil
which is chechnya
and not to do as he speaks about in
a passage just before that
he says
the only move open to us
is to drive a wedge between chechen
separatism and international terrorism
in other words instead of making mascara
the enemy and ahmad the enemy and
murdering the enemies
to try to find allies within the chechen
people to try to deal with the status
issue in a constructive way and to try
to make common cause with them against
the international jihadists whose aim is
to destroy chechnya just as it is the
aim of some russians i think it's a very
constructive approach which he offers in
the book and i think it's something
which the united states has to take very
very seriously and cease
simply ignoring uh this fundamental
question the second point uh which i
think uh he calls for in in the book
which i think is much more on the u.s
agenda is the importance of protecting
the new status and independence and
integrity of ukrainian democracy i would
answer that just one more point that
it's also uh important to protect the
new status and integrity and
independence of georgian democracy today
uh
misha
sakashvili will be meeting with
president bush um and he is a strong
leader
i think he
deeply wants and needs u.s support i
think if these two countries can
preserve their status
russia is going to try to do what it can
to try to undermine that status but if
this can be preserved i think it's the
beginning of a new relationship
with russian democracy it will show
models of
of countries that once were part of the
soviet union which are achieving
successful democracy and integration
with the west
and that should be promoted uh looking
down looking toward the future when
russia itself will be
a full democracy and integrated with the
west whereas andre says over and over
again in the book
which is where it rightly belongs
and finally the point which i don't
think andre deals with sufficiently in
the book and i want to challenge him to
deal with more is the whole issue of
civil society and the uh
and the struggle that's taking place in
russia today uh to destroy the
independence of the ngos uh it's been
mentioned that on the 15th of july the
g8 summit will open
next tuesday july 11th there will be a
meeting in russia called the other
russia
of ngo leaders
and political opposition leaders just
today
july 5th
independent human rights organizations
met and issued an appeal uh to the g8
leaders uh to
deal with all of the issues of of the
the kinds of issues and problems that uh
andre is talking about in the book
including uh including chechnya
i think their voice needs to be listened
to uh everyone knows about the new uh
ngo law which russia uh approved in in
january i think the the civil society
people feel
that the full impact of this law will be
felt after the summit starting july 18th
when the pressure of the summit is
lifted signals have to be sent i think
during the
during the summit
that
this issue
is going to be watched very very closely
andre uh has written in a paper which he
prepared for this meeting but which he
didn't note
made a point which i agree with where he
said
democracy in russia is primarily a
matter for russians i agree with that
completely but
russians and russian
independent organizations and democrats
need support from the west and they
deserve support from the west and that
support is proper and we should not
permit
the russian government putin his
political technologist to delegitimize
that support by saying that somehow
um
uh that this is uh interference in the
internal affairs of russia putin just
said to the press that the council of
europe reviewed the ngo law and approved
the ngo law they never did uh they found
many problems with this law um and i
think that uh we should use the fact
among other things that the the ruble
has just been made convertible that
obviously russia is interested in
economic growth and and economic
integration with the international
uh economy
we should use the leverage that that
derives from that as well as our
political influence to try to protect
civil society uh all the other in
sectors of uh of russian life the media
uh the judiciary the the the provincial
governments the political party system
and so forth the integrity and the
independence of these sectors has pretty
much been ended uh civil society is the
last remaining stronghold of independent
activity and i think it's critical that
we work together with the
democrats in russia to preserve that and
to build upon that for the future thanks
thank you very much andrei will respond
to all the panelists at the end the next
speaker is andres ausland
who is an expert in post-communist
economic transformation he is currently
a senior fellow at the institute for
international economics from 1994 to
2005
he worked at the carnegie endowment for
international peace both of these are
washington dc based think tanks and at
one point at carnegie he ran their
russian and eurasia program
anders has also served as the senior
economic adviser to the governments of
russia ukraine and kyrgyzstan and of
course and he has many publications to
his credit
thank you very much and uh
first of all i would like to
congratulate andre on an
excellent book this is a very good read
so read it fast through and you feel
that you have a good sense of what the
situation is in russia today and i think
that it's thoughtful sharp uh
insightful
i think there is one sentence in the
book that sort of captures most of it
over the last 100 years russian history
has gone full circle and we are back
where we started
and frankly i don't think that's too bad
it's much better than the soviet system
and after all the tsari system didn't
last so
long
if we go back 100 years or so so this is
a system that
could develop so i see a certain hope in
that
sentence and another fundamental insight
in the book is that this is pretty much
a criminal
economic organization that
is running
the state
and
if we look upon the six putin years
today there can be no doubt and i
congratulate andre on having been very
clear on it early on that
the main putin project was to build
authoritarianism in russia and he has
been
very systematic and very successful in
this
task indeed freedom house
ranks the success here
quite extraordinary russia is the only
country that has managed to move from
partially free to unfree in the last six
years
so this has been systematic
the other task where putin has been very
successful so far has been economic
growth russia has had an average growth
of 6.7 percent properly measured and no
problem with the measurement here
during the last seven years there are
the countries that have done even better
but this is
a quite
outstanding
and
the danger today
is that you put these two observations
together
and say that it's better with
authoritarianism for economic growth we
have a danger of the new authoritarian
myth
that i think is very important
to fight and i would argue that there
are essentially two reasons for this
splendid economic growth that we have
seen one is a critical mass of
liberalization stabilization and pre
privatization
that came into friction ironically with
a russian financial crash of 98 that
sort of cleared out the system in
hindsight we can say that this was the
catharsis that russian capitalism
uh needed
and we can particularly see this is in
the oil industry in the
metallurgy that everyone vibes
splendidly or for that matter in the
previously so hopeless coal industry and
all these have revived splendidly under
private ownership
putin didn't play a role there he was
just
a beneficiary of
prior developments and the other point
cause
of course high oil prices currently the
russian economic growth is driven by the
consumer sectors retail trade and
housing construction which is good but
it's thanks to massive
oil surplus uh during putin's three
years he did undertake a lot of economic
reforms so if you look up on the
economic side of putin
which andre does not discuss that much
in his book
the turning point is 2003
and
i would of course emphasize the arrest
of
michael kadarkovsky the chairman of
yokos on the 25th of october
2003
because of that very event putin had to
abandon his tax reform because he had
decided to tax youkos to death
which he successfully did
and
the other was that he needed to do away
with the judicial reform which he
equally successfully did
so what we are seeing here is a quiet
person who doesn't say what is it
on doing and he does is a very uh
systematically and we can only judge
afterwards what he has actually done do
you remember all these things that putin
said about democracy andre sensibly
never
believed them but there are lots of such
statements and
we can only see afterwards that this was
a not on so what is the essence of this
regime today
i would completely agree with andre it's
a seizure of assets
what has happened in the last year is
that five percent of russia's gdp has
been renationalized this is one of the
biggest
re-nationalizations
uh
that we have seen in
post-socialist times and at the same
time we are seeing a reinforcement of
the authoritarianism
and
the third feature that is becoming more
clearly that andre discusses very well
in the last third of his book it is that
the authoritarianism is influencing the
foreign policy of russia in a negative
fashion
and by the way what about corruption
corruption has been increasing after
2004 in russia before that it was
declining according to transparency
international and now in the last
measurement for the first time
transparency international
shows that russia is more corrupt than
ukraine
and here you see the effect of democracy
and transparency and wonderful scandals
in the media they do influence
corruption so that it's
being reduced and what about the u.s
role in this um
state of affairs richard cited the
president bush's most famous statement
about president putin
at the first meeting but i would like to
turn to
his statement at camp david
on the 27th of september 2003
three months after the yuko's affair had
started and i quote
this is in the prepared statement by the
president i respect president putin's
vision for russia a country at peace
within its borders
with its neighbors and with the world
a country in which democracy and freedom
and rule of law thrive
end of quote
and
four weeks afterwards
president putin arrested khodarkovsky
obviously having understood
that president bush would in no way
protest against such an event
so we can't say that the u.s didn't have
an opportunity to influence we can
clearly say that the u.s did not
influence events in any
positive
way
so
what
should the
u.s president do in this
situation
well the first and most obvious thing
is that he should not praise him
for what is not doing
and
that the
words should at least be
truthful and turning now to the g8
summit in saint petersburg
i would argue that the three most
important us interest with regard to
russia concern democracy
in the whole region
the sovereign secondly the sovereignty
of the other former
republics
and thirdly energy security and on the
first two points the important thing is
to make public statements that are clear
enough
i think the worst that could happen to
president bush
is if
the president put in
afterwards and access abrasia which he
has threatened publicly this year to do
and if there's not a clear us statement
on record
that
this would be absolutely
intolerable
the positive part of the agenda is
energy security and i think that there
are essentially two big issues that
could and should be accomplished one is
the huge stockman
gas field in the arctic sea
that could and should
produce lng for delivery to the u.s this
would be a big positive connection
between russia and the u.s and the other
is access to the russian gas pipeline
system
for europe
probably that could not be agreed
directly but a big step in that
direction could be made that's primarily
for the
europeans so all together this is not
much and if you can't accomplish much
anyhow why not at least make sure that
you stand up and make a truthful
statement in particular when you have
such statements that you should eat up
from
before
more broadly what should the west do
with russia
i very much agree with congressman's
line here we should work for integration
russia is now very close to conclude a
bilateral
accession agreement to the w-2
with the u.s
virtually nothing remains i think that
this will be concluded by the summit and
i think that this is something that we
should welcome
the integration of russia economically
strengthens the liberal forces uh in
russia for the same reason i would be in
favor of lng deliveries from russia
to the
the u.s
but what should we do about these
corrupt people at the top in the kremlin
well we have one good example of what
can be done the private alpha group for
its own commercial reasons is pursuing
minister of communications leonid
raymond a close friend of
putin's from saint petersburg
and
what they have revealed in courts is
that raymond has
benefited in the order of one billion
dollars in telecommunication assets
while being minister of
telecommunications
and this a private
russian group has done no western
government has bothered to deal with
this and you wonder then as andre
mentions
in his book the purchase by
a gas prom of uh
cbneft for 13 billion dollars
and
we don't know
how much a kickback there was the
general assumption is that there was
something between one and 11 billion
dollars we don't know
but you would expect some western
government to investigate this given
that the transaction has been
taking place
in the west so this is something that i
can't quite understand that the western
governments are not going after
what is obviously
just about the largest
money laundering cases that we could see
in the world
in all probability undertaking by top
russian
officials who barely hide their business
activities at the same time as this
could decide which way russia goes for
the future thank you
and thank you our last speaker will be
david sayed to setter who is currently a
senior fellow at the hudson institute
he has covered soviet and russia affairs
as a correspondent for both the
financial times and the wall street
journal he has written numerous articles
and two books about russia the first the
age of delirium decline and fall of the
soviet union is currently being made
into a documentary film and the second
is darkness dawn the rise of of the
russian criminal
david
rise of the russian criminal state
state
russian criminals existed uh
have existed for a long time
unfortunately
i've had the uh
the honor to be the editor of uh andre's
book i've known andre for a long time
and uh we're also good
good friends
and i've read many of his articles in
the russian press
over the years
working on the book
uh i was able to
uh understand really
the philosophy and
the the world view that underpins his uh
his journalistic writing and what it
confirmed for me is something that's uh
of which we're oftentimes not fully
aware and that is the existence of a
liberal
and
uh humane
political tradition in russia
which is capable of guiding the
country's destinies despite all the talk
about russian peculiarity russia's
special way
the russian approach to democracy the
fact that russians don't understand
democracy is in the way that what the
west understands it what the book
demonstrates is that there are russians
who understand democracy perfectly well
no less well than people in this country
or any other western country and that
they are absolutely capable
of seeing in the clearest terms what is
happening in russia and the degradation
to which the country is being led by its
aspiration to authoritarianism
i've always felt on the basis of my
observations in russia that the real
problem
in russia the kind of ariadne's thread
which is essential for understanding
russia and and
and according and which really relates
to everything else is the imbalance in
the country between the power of the
state and the dignity of the individual
it's clear
and all democracy prejudice presupposes
it
that without respect for the
inalienable rights of the individual and
his inherent dignity it's impossible to
exercise real control over the
government apparatus and the whole of
russian history
beginning with the tsarist period
reaching
absolutely inhuman extremes under the
communist period and today in the
post-communist area demonstrates the
consequences
of an uncontrolled government machine
which regards
the citizens of the of of of russia not
as human beings in their own right not
as ends in themselves which is essential
to the western tradition but rather as
means to an end
the consequence of all this
in my view
is that russia under the pressure of
this hypertrophic state apparatus
has a very
questionable and tenuous understanding
of ethical transcendence
the idea
that rules apply equally to all
that there are rules that are over and
above the realm of society over and
above the interests of individual human
beings and over and above the interests
of the state
and that the state no less than the
individual is obliged to conduct itself
in accordance with those rules
what we see now
as the authoritarianism of the yeltsin
era
is now has now reached its logical
expression in the
authoritarianism of the putin era
is the attempt really to hold the state
up
as itself a source of values
not rather than something rather than as
an entity which is in need of moral
guidance and this expresses itself
i think in in various ways all of which
are are very dangerous not only for
russians
but for the rest of the world as well
it's clear
that the that the the upshot of the
development of authoritarianism uh the
perfection of authoritarianism under
putin
is to eliminate once and for all the
possibility that the russian people will
ever choose their own rulers
if you look at all of the things that
have happened the kharkovsky case the
control of the media the the the new law
on ngos the the direct appointment of
governors which may be followed by the
direct appointment of mayors
what you see is a situation in which
those who hold power now are preparing
the groundwork for a system which will
allow them to keep power no matter what
the will of the population that doesn't
mean necessarily that putin will
continue in office although he could and
i think that question has not been
resolved what it means is that a system
is in place which will make it possible
for those who who
aspire to rob the population and to hang
on to their
ill-gotten wealth will never be
challenged and the many questions which
exist and many of them were raised in
andre's book
about how exactly putin got to be
president of russia will never be
answered
putin regime has every reason to fear
going into opposition
i
the terrorist acts which have taken
place in russia in many cases are
unexplained beginning with the 1999
apartment buildings and continuing with
the with the uh terrorist outrages in
the nordost
uh performance in the theater in
dubrovka and in beslan
the uh
situation
in which
those who the the oligarchs and those
who hold ma you know
who who who are who are extremely
wealthy in russia are in fear of
contributing to any other political
force except that force which which
supports the the present oligarchy
and in which uh all television is in
effect in the hands of the regime not to
mention the government apparatus
more or less assures or appears to
assure
that that there are insuperable
obstacles to replacing putin and raising
fundamental issues
about the way in which the country is
governed and the way in which
the wealth of the country is being uh
disposed of
beyond that
uh we see in russia's foreign policy
the absence of a sense
of genuine ethics and genuine moral
behavior
russia is a natural geopolitical ally of
the united states and the reason for
this is simple we have the same enemies
russia and
the united states are both interested
in balancing the growing power of china
and certainly are threatened by demented
islamic extremism
under these circumstances russia has
every interest in being a part of the
west and can coordinating its foreign
policy with the foreign policy of the
west
instead what does it do it supplies
anti-aircraft missiles to iran
encourages the iranian nuclear weapons
program provides advanced military
technology to china and attempts to
discourage the development of democracy
in countries like ukraine which can only
infect uh
the development of which can only work
to the benefit of the world and to and
to russia itself
the attitude
of the russians toward
a people's right
to decide its own decide on its own
government was demonstrated in the
ukrainian elections when in the face of
massive vote vote fraud
yeltsin hurried not once but twice to
congratulate yanukovych on his quote
unquote convincing victory
but more than this
and
reflecting the other two factors
is the fact that
russia uh is and the present russian
leadership in defiance of all common
common sense
and all intellectual integrity is trying
to develop
some type
of new authoritarian ideology
it has been the misfortune of russia to
assume that there was some special
russian way
to improve on the universal moral values
of civilization there of course is no
such word there is no way to improve
upon them they've estab they it is those
values which come down to us from the
bible through the judeo-christian
tradition are the only way of regulating
human behavior in a in a in a moral
fashion and no talk about a special
russian way the special prerogatives of
the russian state the supposed uh
uh
which masked by claims for superior
spirituality
is going to be an improvement over the
simple precepts of right and wrong
that govern
the behavior of all truly democratic
governments and yet
beginning with high
officials of the russian orthodox church
recently metropolitan kirill
and followed by alexander solzhenitsyn
leading russian of
russian political literary and
intellectual figures have suggested that
human rights are not universally
applicable what matters is obligations
well who is to impose these obligations
this is not this is not uh
when in fact you the the very notion of
rights
indicates the defense of the individual
the individual against his government
under these circumstances
russia
gives every appearance
of once more descending into the kind of
delirium
that has engulfed it in the past and led
to nothing good
in its political and
economic life
russia is a country dotted with mass
graves
by the way many of which have not been
acknowledged graves left over from the
stalin era which no one any longer
bothers
to to to to unearth uh investigate or
even mark
and with this buried heritage to begin
to to
to circulate such
justification justifications for
authoritarianism
in the context of a society which is in
effect dying because of its loss of
population and loss of hope
is really to show
that
all of our hopes for democracy in russia
and the spiritual transformation of the
country are to some extent in vain
and against that background it is
extremely encouraging to read a book
like the book that andre has produced
which although it consists of of short
articles also exists
as a political and even artistic whole
because it
unlike
so many other collections of articles
there's a consistent point of view
there's a an understanding of underlying
values
and there's an indication of the way in
which russia needs to go
if it's to save itself
and to avoid
the false ideas and the false values
that have have so ruined the and the the
the political life of the country in the
past
under these circumstances um you know it
was great great honor for me to work to
work on the book with andre and i
very much hope
that people in the american government
who've been oftentimes very superficial
in their attitude toward russia will
take the time to read this book
especially on the eve of the g8 meeting
which presents a great opportunity for
us once again since we've made the
mistake of giving russia status it
doesn't deserve of reaffirming for
russia what we mean by universal values
and the importance of democracy
thank you very much david andre do you
want to take a minute or two and just
respond to the panel's comments
well maybe wait then
you want to do okay
um
well now moves to questions and answers
uh please wait for the mic to come and
then identify yourself
also indicate which panelists
to which panels you are addressing your
question and also speak slowly and
clearly since we have a lot of foreign
media broadcasts in this regard and in
that sense i'd like to ask the media to
po to allow a lot of the media to pose
their questions first since you have uh
deadlines which
uh any media questions
seeing none we will then proceed to
general questions
uh do you want to give it to the
gentleman
uh chris shaffer i was wondering if you
could say this is really to anyone who
who wants to answer the question sorry
if if um or maybe even andre can you
talk a little bit about uh putin's
popularity in the country um and you
we've sort of outlined concerns about um
the the the trends in the country but is
he popular with the russian people that
sort of thing
yes
according uh according to opinion paul
putin
if election
where today he would
get well
either slightly more than 50 percent or
slightly less than 50 percent
and
certainly
um
will be rare accurate uh this attitude
is a
combination of two reasons
uh first uh very variable comparison uh
with yes and people in the eyes of uh
population which uh regularly did not
get their salary and pensions uh during
calcium period and now
because of this
oil prices
state have enough money enough money
to
fulfill its
immediate
immediate obligation the second reason
it's a complete dominance
of
state tv there's only one
one
political figure
and
people simply uh don't
know any any other
other other alternatives
but i would say that
this is not
why uh
um i almost skeptical about uh opinion
posts because opinion posts work a very
important parameter intensity of your
support well a person
comes to the street and asking are you
for the putin or the primakov you are
answering yes uh or no
uh
let me remind you that uh mr primakov
who was crushed by this
success operation
designed by berezovsky and
executed
by putin election campaign was very
popular figure um
in the summer of 1990 the same even even
higher figures uh 75
percent well uh
yes and ceremoniously throw him out
from his post
she seat of the prime minister
and what happened where were these
75
percent
who were supporting mr premakov they
didn't get to the street standing
primark of primakov so i think it's
it's
a case
not of enthusiastic passion as
supportive the case
of uh
of lack of choice and
and
[Music]
a work of uh other other opportunities
um
let me expand a bit uh um answering your
question about uh
perspectives of
of of this regime it's not threatened by
any democratic revolution
there was some
fears in kremlin immediately after
ukrainian elections that orange
revolution instigated by
uh foreigners
will happen tomorrow and the criminal
propaganda is crying that
front line is going through every street
every house and so on well now they come
down and
realize that
nothing's certain and there will be not
there will be no opportunity to change
this regime uh by democratic election
because there will be no democratic
collection
but
this kind of regime has an internal
internal problem internal weakness the
problem of transition and now it's when
it's passed through transition period
the inevitable the divisions inside the
ruling group
uh it's inevitable and we're already
watching the first sign with this uh
mysterious setting of uh
general prosecutor this certainly was a
result of
fierce fighting of two
competing
competing clients
and
if during this
internal fighting some other figure
will appear
well i think that
in two three weeks of
indoctrination
by state
or in tv companies well
this figure will get
the same figure is the same level of
of support like like mr putin
okay the gentleman in the pink short
place ben
thank you i'm mike halsell i thought it
was terrific presentation all four of
you uh on today you uh
toward the end of your talk you you said
that the murderer of the russian
diplomat and the
three other embassy employees in baghdad
was evidence that uh
we have common interests russia in the
united states against islamofascism and
whatever one thinks of the
wisdom of the iraq war i
think that's indisputably true
unfortunately the
preponderant media reaction in russia
was rather vetupative anti-americanism
not
attacking the people who did the
murdering
and
we even got a an insight further insight
into the list when somebody left the
microphone inadvertently on at the g8
ministerial and we heard sergey lavrov
yes
in a duel with the condoleezza rice over
this my question is
has the
virtual
monopoly by the government of the
electronic media in russia
managed to change public opinion about
the danger of this islamofascism or is
this just the establishment talking
um i think if haven't managed it can't
change the perception of russian
islamic
people
danger
but certainly it has changed
perception of russian people about
united states
well it was usually phenomena
during class 10 years as well uh the
basic level of anti-american uh feeling
what's about 20 20 percent usually
regard america as a threat to russia
it's quite natural after after history
of the court war uh then
um
time from time uh tv launch
some hysterical anti-american campaign
sometimes on serious reason for example
war in yugoslavia
sometimes on just preposterous for
example humiliation of russian sportsmen
during salt lake olympic games
and after this campaign
continued for a couple of weeks
uh well this uh figures jumped to
45 for example but campaign ended
everybody forget about milosevic or
russian sportsman resumed
and so he said it's
returned to basic figure uh to 20
from this famous uh
putin's statement after beswan which i i
quote this
propaganda is going on for two years
for 24 hours
and now the results were i looked so
figures just yesterday and what is very
funny well certainly
i was not surprised that
well i was surprised that figure is uh
comparatively modest about 43 percent of
preparation uh regards uh
america so this 43 which they managed to
keep for two weeks now they
they keep permanently but what's
absolutely funny it's uh
the list of the countries
five countries are perceived by most
dangerous enemies of russia with the
right in quebec lithuania uh estonia
united states of america and georgia
but
it speaks a word such combination
speaks a word it means that
after this tv
indoctrination
uh people have a very schizophrenic a
very schizophrenic uh
viewer on the wall and you're absolutely
right about this this reaction uh to the
tragedy of our diplomat was
just indecent both
on official level on official level they
make the statement that certainly united
states keeps our responsibility well
maybe it's the same thing sense like
putin personally keeps responsibility
for death of 300 russian children in a
in
in this one
but uh
talking um
talking hats
on state tv
even indict relating uh implicitly
sometimes very explicitly the idea that
well our muslim friends couldn't do it
certainly it's operation
organized and by cia and
something
like this
well on the day after beheading uh his
diplomats putin and dress all
foreign
foreign ministers notable
well these three ideas that we should
change our relations with america
certainly
you understand in what direction second
that we can't join any uh as he
put it sacred
alliance
it's uh just
repeating the famous level of formula
that well russia is not taking sight
in this conflict unleashed by well maybe
iraq more
instigated by the united states and the
third
that
well
in non-proliferation agenda we
decisively against any any ultimatums
the statements make mockery of so-called
joint
six power statements
on iran moreover during his
very friendly meetings
uh in shanghai with a
person who
wants a weak uh calls for wiping
israel out of the map uh
putin mentioned uh
first is that
where iran should have some uh facility
for scientific um
enrichment of iranian and talking with
these
russian correspondents mentioned that
well our muslim friends are making a
vote for freeing uh our diplomats
the role of iran in this
in this tragedy was sinister because
iran doesn't conceal uh its connection
this uh this group is this so-called
jihadi insurer and moreover during this
crisis uh iran's makes several time
statements that well we can be helpful
if russia asked us nicely so it was a
kind of blackmailing profession and
putin so sensitive to any encroachment
of on on pride and honor of russian
states
well
he calls us to such uh to such behavior
it's a very strange it's
it's not explained by any reason of
state security explained by complexes uh
of russian
and and unfortunately putin uh i i
described putin in iran in vanuatu as
the most outstanding mediocrity of our
political class paraphrasing the famous
uh
trotsky formula um
about
stalin and as a mediocrity of our
political certainly he shares all these
complexes and frustration but as
outstanding mediocrity in the
september 2002 he took a very wise
decision and now what what is doing now
just contrary to his philosophy uh of
uh that period so this uh frustration
conferences prevail i'm afraid
irrevocably in putin's mind in and
putting so
over the consideration of uh stash
reason and
national security would any of the other
panelists like to add any comments to
the last two questions
okay uh the
person in the back and the uh the shirt
my name is brian
intern here at hudson um
on page six of uh andre's new book he
writes enough of putin ultimately he is
a replaceable figure if there was no
putin there would be a poopin what
matters is putinism a toolkit to enable
the authorities to keep themselves in
power
so my question is who makes up the vast
and powerful group of authorities
who you're writing about here are they
holdovers from the old soviet union are
they simply rich people who are part of
the oligarchy of crony capitalists who
dominate russia's economy who are these
people
well
let me look at the page six
at that time
at this time certainly it was a chronic
capitalist around yeltsin family
i briefly touched this issue they
appointed putin was not elected election
was a campaign
exercise of
tv
public relations first he was appointed
uh
personally berezovsky uh ocean um head
of
the yeltsin administration yes and
daughter tatiana uh her boyfriend
yamashif this uh
actually four or five people maybe
abramowicz also was part
of this
of this group they appointed putin to be
no old
soviet uh
people from
67 now
the problem of
so-called successor is decided
by a new business group by new business
growth which includes putin himself of
course
and
his
closest
kgb associates but it's not from a top
soviet kgb it was a very middle rank
people who served with him in dresden or
in san peterborough
searching uh
ukunian uh this
uh
other people
and uh
well they haven't
david was right they haven't yet decided
what was the mechanism
uh uh i
looking into putin so
for very long time and i think i
understand him a bit
uh well
i think he he personally he is not very
eager to to to run for cert
for certain term
uh here already is very versatile person
and
human mayor joy west of
his wife somewhere in french helps of
something like this
but
people around many people around here
don't see any any future
without putin because in russia losing
power is losing wealth the 10 15 people
who rule
russia now the
current politburo these same people all
russia they owe
all the main oil i guess
as such
of the country and for them it's a
very important issue
who will be
the next president and
i already noted that it's quite problems
it's a very serious division during this
uh this transition uh period one more
point provoked by your questions
but rather
uh referring to previous question on
russian foreign policy there is a new
factor in russian foreign policy
uh well look
at this
15 people who lose russia and who owes
russia
and what if
in their life stability of regime
their political power
their world
prestige
and their personal awareness after all
depends
on one figure number of doors for barrel
of oil
and they remember very well
uh
the collapse of soviet union after the
oil prices uh collapsed in
middle fighters and believe me these
people will not be passive observers of
volatility of oil prices in the world
they have a lot of political as a
leaders
a very important power they have a lot
to of member a permanent member of
security council super nuclear power
super energy powers another they have a
lot of leverage
to influence on this this figure and i
think
a lot of
uh in russian policy around iran
is ex moscow policy about iran explained
now by their desire to keep
oil prices as high
as possible
not only me but any russian any russian
speaker
in washington
even if he represents the government i
think they always ask one one question
why russia is so reckless uh so
like-minded about
prospect of iran acquiring uh nuclear
weapon nuclear weapon well it's because
by the way don't forget that iran is the
only state which officially have
territorial claims uh
to russian federation i mean the the
caspian uh entourage
casper
caspian sea surface and by
projection uh
in
2040 there will be one million russian
and one
100 million russian and 105 million
iranian
and the answer very simple because
people in moscow are
well you may say
anything about them but they are stupid
they know
very perfectly well that iran will never
have a nuclear bomb that either united
states or israel will deal
with this
disease problem
and
practically
the right is putin's statement we are
against any ultimatum in
non-proliferation it means that
moscow will not allow security council
never to take
any a real sanction
against uh against iran means that the
iranian regime will have no incentive to
stop of nuclear problem
it means that sooner or later rather
sooner israel will make its
preventive strike it it's the best case
scenario for this 10 15 people in moscow
first well a serious
iran nuclear problem will be solved
second
all the fury of islamic world will be
channeled certainly against israel
united states and the third and most
important can you imagine a crisis about
this action because iran doesn't
conceive that as a territory um
a territory step it certainly block
heat
saudi platform and hermes trades and
block block any oil
experts
from middle as well two hundred four
hundred thousand baby
okay we have a question from the media
actually
just look into it identify identify
yourself radio free asia gregory
um uh the question is a little bit out
of the topic of today but if
if you don't mind to look into the mind
of putin
however for the north korean they
they're testing the missile uh wouldn't
this would uh putin be more happy there
to see the north korean testing missile
or what are the response from the
from the uh the russian side uh since we
have not much information we need uh
nowadays from from the russian side what
actually putin would do if you look into
the mind of himself
thank you uh very very interesting
question thank you because it reminds me
um it reminds me of this this story of
putin and north korea missiles
is an interesting story
uh do you remember in 2000 yes in 2000
there was summit in okinawa
g8 summit in okinawa is the first uh
potentiate summer on the way to okinawa
putin visited north korea
and uh
he came to okinawa and well very
enthusiastically declared that i
i brought a decision the problem and mr
kim cheney promised
me that there will be no missile
development no test uh no missile
development well yesterday's event is
it's very very good uh illustration well
and uh in two weeks uh
kimchi
it was a joke a joke with mr putin it's
very interesting that mr putin is uh
obsessed uh or rather not putin i i talk
it it's
it's
obsession of russian political class uh
generally obsessed with this uh so
obsessed with an animosity to the west
and the united
st others just make make fun of them
answering directly to the question what
mr putin can do nothing
nothing is in the case of
of
iran putin has some leverage and
and use them rather skillfully for
example we have
no time to talk in details
about supply of russian anti-aircraft
missiles
um tm1 to iran which makes this israeli
strikes more and more probable but
north korea
moscow has
no level of chateau china has some
serious
leverage
but not russia okay in the interest of
atlanta time i'd like to let everybody
ask their question and then the
panelists can respond to those points
which most interests them so why don't
we proceed
starting in the back moving towards the
front
so go ahead and please identify yourself
and then ask your question my name is
michael mclaughlin with united press
international
and there was kind of
unanimity among the panelists that
russia the u.s have an interest in
fighting
islamic terrorism together but it's
possible that the united states really
has an interest in seeing russia
weakened by islamic terrorism and that
will make it easier for them to support
democracy in ukraine or georgia or
acquire energy security in europe
give me a post
my name is valentine's
i'm a senior economist with the cave
economics assistant and a professor at
erc here
here at canada institute fellow right
now
and i have a question
to
to
everybody else especially to the
specialist and the soul of putin
what is what is your opinion on the
uh attitude of soul of putin
towards ukraine
especially to
foreign and economic policy to
gas issues and also territorial issues
crimea and usl island thank you
barry wood voice america
i think uh particularly to mr satter but
anyone else
you've suggested that russia doesn't
belong in the ga
well it's in
as we all know
what does that mean for the process to
have a authoritarian increasingly
authoritarian state in does that suggest
that we should go further and widen the
club or should the club be disbanded or
what are your thoughts on this
ron mcnamara with the helsinki
commission uh there were a couple of
references to quotes by president
bush
but i wonder if you could address the
question of vice president cheney's
thinking on russia in the in the lead up
now to the g8 summit
um
for york radio liberty uh andre would
you be willing to name some of the
political technologists that you may
have identified in your book and then a
question to everyone which is these uh
this concept of somehow russia being
unique and having a unique path to
development is mirrored or surfaces in
all of the former soviet space
now is this uh and it undermines
democracy in all of the former soviet
states as well so i like a comment from
others
angela sten from georgetown university
andre you describe very eloquently how
russia has got to where it is now what
putinism is but we know that it won't
remain like that forever what are the
sources of change how is this particular
system going to unravel because even if
the people at the top want to stay in
power or keep the system forever they
can't so what what causes change
are there any more questions
okay we have one more moment up here
please
foster i have a verified question to
all four
panelists and anybody can answer
um we in the congress of british
americans absolutely
cannot figure out what was there first
the chicken or the egg implicit in all
the few talks was
the the
accusations and the annuity between
american media american administration
american intellectuals and russian media
in russia
russian government
representatives and so who was who
started it who was there first
i'd like to go and reverse the order of
the presentations beginning with david
please
well
starting with the question that was
addressed specifically to me i don't
think that russia should continue to be
a member of the g8 if it if it evolves
in a
authoritarian direction at the same time
the fact that it is a member
and will not be easily removed from the
organization does give the other members
of the g8 an opportunity to exert
influence on russia
by speaking frankly to russia and
and threatening them literally with
expulsion from the organization and
exclusion in various forms it's possible
to limit to a certain extent the
authoritarian evolution of the country
we don't want the situation in russia to
become even worse
and although russians hate
the
the criticism that they often get from
the west about human rights abuses and
similar things the fact is that they do
listen to it because they understand
that it's legitimate however much they
may pretend uh to the contrary
regarding some of the other issues that
were raised i think that
the west has no interest
in using islamic terrorism or anything
else in order to weaken russia a
weakened russia is a danger to the west
no less than a danger to its own people
what is weakening russia right now is
its own authoritarian evolution as a
result of the increasing
a tendency toward dictatorship in russia
corruption is increasing exponentially
the country is becoming more brutal and
uh
as a result is creating enemies for
itself that it doesn't need
and the the the flames so to speak of
islamic extremism are being stoked even
more
chechnya although it often isn't
mentioned in the western press in this
context is really the second
justification for islamic extremism
after the arab israeli situation
and with with i think considerably more
justice actually
and
many of the people who
have surfaced as suicide bombers or
islamic terrorists at one time or
another wanted to go to chechnya to
fight the russians as they saw it
the we don't you know there's an
information blockade there we don't know
a lot about what's happening but
information does reach the arab world
about the atrocities that have been
committed
and as far as using islamic extremism
the
recent terrorist acts and the many many
questions which surround those terrorist
acts in russia itself rays can
much more legitimately raise the
question of who is trying to use
islamic extremism and for what purpose
thank you three uh a quick responses
two three questions uh rob mcnamara's
chain is thinking good
the problem with chinese speech was that
there was neither leader nor follow-up
so it lacks credibility it's
just as in order to put out
as a sort of cloud of nervous be
speaking and
anybody of the world can conclude this
is not uh president bush's
thinking
second point barry wood
yes broader g8
if g8 is not a club of industrial
democracies
make it broader so that it becomes more
representative the
eighth biggest economy in the world is
not russia but china russia is the 10th
the economy so it's almost unfair and
india brazil and south africa and then
you have a very representative group and
focus on economic issues
g7 exists for
the ministers of finance and governance
of central banks
keep it broadened ga to g12
valentine's
zelin york's questions about
ukraine i think general the conclusion
in moscow was in the kremlin was that
russia was too soft and therefore it
should be tougher
and
with regard to gas i really don't think
that it's a
primarily political issues what we are
seeing is now that uh
a market price between 120 and 150
dollars per 1000
cubic meters is spreading throughout
the cis regions which in 150
is the netback price from europe so here
i think on the contrary that castrom
is caring very strongly about its market
capitalization enough people in high
positions in moscow do earn substantial
amounts of stocks in gas prom so here we
are actually seeing that the market is
taking over another impetus in this
direction is that gas problem is not
increasing production therefore it needs
to ration
with regard to the increasing
demand
with prices which i basically think is a
good thing then it's a question exactly
how you time it and how you comply with
illegal commitments already undertaken
thank you
thank you carl
uh on the question about the political
technologists just i mean
andre talks about it in the book take a
look at page 78 where he describes
gleb pavlovsky as a character out of the
possessed
and i might note also uh
that we have an article in the current
issue of the journal of democracy on the
political technologists so there's a lot
of writing on that i just want to
address the question of who started it
and again uh something out of andre's
book
uh a book that he refers to repeatedly
in his book
was was written
over a hundred years ago by by tolstoy
uh [ __ ] marad describing a situation 50
years before that in 1852
um and you know this is chechnya 1852. i
mean it's an old problem
uh the problem is that nothing has been
done to address it quite the country
it's just gotten dangerously worse since
then
but i think you know
you know i think that addresses the
whole issue of what the the roots of
this problem are better than anything
else
let me just also say that andre
andre refers repeatedly in the book to
chapter 17 which i urge people to take a
look at but i would also urge take a
look at chapter 15 which is a brilliant
chapter on tsar nicholas the first
uh which may set a model for some of the
uh leadership qualities you see today
thank you very much andrei do you have a
last comment or you want to make and
then then andre will be available
afterwards to sign your books and answer
questions
yes my friends covered almost all
questions
i
[Music]
touch two of them ukraine and change uh
the the sources potential sources of
change by the way this
this tuition very strongly
interconnected
uh well
ukraine development in ukraine certainly
presents very serious threat to moscow
but not
in the sense like kremlin propaganda
described is that
nato tanks will move
from kiev to moscow and so on
the development indicated a very serious
psychological political
uh threat to putin colepocra
kleptocratic regime onto his corporate
state because uh
orange revolution was a rebellion of uh
ukrainian uh
people against the same regime
uh of uh of kuchma
and a lot of ice
in russia are watching what is going in
ukraine if ukraine succeed
in
their declared
new pro-european paths of democratic
state transparent
economy
it will affect events in russia enormous
more than anything else because we in
russia for several harnesses have been
debating this eternal issue whether
we're part of europe or not whether we
european eurasians and so on
we have some success stories in in
eastern europe poland czech uh informal
soviet republic uh
lithuania wetlands but it's not nothing
for russian soul
they are
alien they even brought republics they
were always
alien in the uh soviet union ukrainian
this is a part of us if ukraine is a
cause
people to russia